we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine to david p here is a
voicemail that i received take a listen
hey David I was wondering if either you
or your new interns our employees are
reading youtube comments yeah that'd be
nice to know here's the deal I look at
youtube comments on a regular basis I
know that Jason looks at YouTube
comments on a regular basis the reality
is we get between three and four
thousand youtube comments a day so like
for example this is from I think earlier
today Jason went in and actually
responded to someone on YouTube uh there
was really something directed at Jason
and Jason responded there he signed it J
etc sometimes I will respond to some
comments on YouTube I try to get an
overview of what is happening it's not
realistic Rachel for me to read and
respond to 3,000 YouTube comments a day
is it or to somebody would do you expect
me to do that yes no you know I don't I
mean I think it's important to kind of
be in tune with the general consensus of
your audience and kind of what they're
thinking and have demands and what they
are dislike and like about the show I
think that's really important I'm to
kind of have that relationship with your
audience but in terms of reading every
single comment and while some of them
can be kind of mean uh I don't think
it's feasible yeah I want to have a
sense of did we do any videos that were
particularly disliked that's always of
interest to me and why were they dislike
where they dislike because I took enough
unpopular opinion or they dislike
because we made some kind of stood up
factual mistake etc and then I like to
just sort of get a sense of okay are the
insults about me uh is it geared towards
my face one week or is it more geared
towards my Judaism or is it more geared
towards my clothing or you know to get a
sort of sense of the tone and tenor of
the critiques and also just see where
the audience is on a number of issues I
think that that's that's pretty
legitimate I don't know that I could be
faulted for that but but how would
knowing about the insults help anything
oh it doesn't just personal curiosity
that helps absolutely nothing if
anything it hurts Jason you wanted to
say something yeah I think it's
a good good way to keep in touch with
your fan base no way can you keep in
touch with or can you read rather all
11,000 i think there's eleven thousand
likely spam uh messages right now and
that's on top of the one that top the
ones actually get through to bill
they're so so yeah and by the way we
have the youtube settings set not to
filter out any messages at all we're not
doing any censoring but there is an
automatic youtube spam filter and there
are currently as Jason said 11,000 posts
caught in that which 11,000 out of
overall hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of thousands or even millions
not really that bad on the bonus show
today we will talk about an autonomous
farming tractor that has been been
unveiled sounds like more jobs about to
be destroyed and i also have a really
really good date story which follows up
on two prior stories my senses the
audience is going to absolutely love
this story sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership terrific bonus show
today